quickly I know you also you think lots  of people on the album using Kanye for  letting me shine to give him your start  hmm  we saw him kind of have some struggles  over the weekend and now canceled his  tour yeah is he going through something  is he I you know I haven't spoken to him  since that so I'm not gonna speak out of  turn and try to speak for him all I can  see is what he said to the public and  that he's tired and needs some rest and  I think he's been through a lot lately  with what happened to him and and you  know I think you know if he needs to  rest in I think his fans will be patient  let him rest and he'll come back  stronger hopefully he's the one that  signed me he's the one that helped  discover me and help me get a record  deal and I wouldn't be where I am now  without him so I'm very grateful to him  okay thank you thank you